all right hello everyone my name is Oh
Dora I'm one of the partners at Y
Combinator I have roham from app deaf go
Alana from bulletin and Tiffany from the
human utility today today we're going to
talk about our discussion will be around
essential startup advice so I think
there's a lot of actually good advice in
books articles and even on Twitter
sometimes but they tend to be I think
very generic and abstract and it's not
to try to to make it apply to everybody
as much as possible so today I want to
go over some of that common advice you
probably see and dive deep one level
deeper into how it applies to these
three folks and their startups and go
from there so the most common advice I
hear all the time and I give all the
time is make something people want it's
so common that's almost the motto of Y
Combinator
so maybe you guys can start off with
introducing yourselves and what's the
one-liner for what you're building and
how did you know why did you think it
was something people wanted hi everyone
I'm Rehan figuri co-founder and CEO of
ab deco we are a marketplace for buying
and selling furniture base here in New
York City so if you're selling furniture
definitely check out ab deco i have to
plug all the time so the reason why I
started epic I was actually out of my
own frustration trying to sell furniture
on Craigslist had a really bad
experience realized that there are
something has to be done to make it
better and more efficient so we are one
stop solution we take care of the pickup
and delivery we handle payments online
we verify everything before pickup and
that was the reason why we started is
because it out of my own frustration
right hi guys I'm Alana Branston
co-founder and CEO of bulletin bulletin
is we work for retail space so we build
physical retail stores we're direct
consumer brands can sell their products
for a monthly membership fee so we have
two stores here in New York the stores
are actually filled with all female-led
brands so yeah it's completely for women
by women and yeah when we started the
business we actually did not build
something that people wanted at all like
it was a disaster
we started off with it was basically
like an Etsy competitor it was like a
cool curated Etsy was the idea we like
literally didn't sell anything it didn't
work and then we started talking to
those users and basically asked them
okay like what can we do that is helpful
because this clearly is not and figured
out that they wanted access to retail
space and how hard it was for them to
get into stores so yeah we eventually
built something people wanted it just
took a while hey everybody I'm Tiffany
Ashley Bell I am the founder and
executive director of a not-for-profit
organization called the human utility
where we essentially pay water bills for
people that can't afford their own we've
done that for like a thousand families
in Detroit and Baltimore and a bunch of
surrounding cities since thank you thank
you
it's not really we either it's all you
guys have donated but you know we've
done that for a thousand families since
we started in July 2014 and it was more
of make something people need we
essentially crowd fund the money to help
people and I just read one day I'm not
from Detroit or anything like that I
just read about what was happening in
Detroit because I was actually working
in City Hall Atlanta and I was just
thinking to myself like what kinds of
failures had to happen in City Hall
where somebody just decided that if
you're poor we'll turn your water off
and I thought that was pretty crappy so
friends and I got together and just
decided to like you know well we'll
throw away a hundred bucks and then in a
weekend on some shirt we don't need in a
bad restaurant so why not give that to
you know people to help with their water
bills but it's hurting like the whole
internet wanting to do that so I've been
doing that ever since
awesome okay so another piece of advice
is do things that don't scale so give us
one example of something that you did
that wasn't really scalable you have to
do it anyway and maybe it's related to
how you got your first user I have a lot
but so when we first started I don't
know how many people are doing
marketplaces but the big problem with
marketplace is this they call it the
chicken and egg problem is you need to
get you know content and also buyers and
so how do we convince people to actually
transact in our on our platform so how
do I get furniture
platform where nobody will trust that I
actually am a real legitimate business
was the question that we were trying to
tackle so we were going on Craigslist
the reason why I actually built the
platform is because of Craigslist but we
were going on Craigslist just telling
people hey you should try App Deco you
know we are gonna take care of delivery
except direct sector because after some
people you know we're convinced enough
to list but the part that actually came
out of one of my partner meetings at YC
was instead of having people you email
them and have them go list on your
website why don't you just list it for
them and so that was like oh wow is that
even kosher I mean I don't think it is
but so we just started just going on
Craigslist and the tree just copying
content from Craigslist to our site and
then there's a whole other story of like
once something's sold how did we get it
to the customer that's a whole different
story
yeah for us we basically when we were
pivoting from this like Etsy competitor
idea to the retail space idea we really
didn't have any money I think we had 20k
that we had gotten from YC fellowship
and we're like okay how are we gonna
test like a retail space concept and so
my co-founder and I it was just the two
of us at the time started doing these
like outdoor weekend flea markets as a
way to test the concept so we literally
rented out this like overgrown vacant
parking lot in Williamsburg it was like
a toxic wasteland and we had all these
brands come we'd had like 40 brands come
every weekend and they would come and
like set up their product and sell and
like it actually went really well we're
like they were making a lot of money we
were making money finally and we used
that to basically prove that like okay
brands will show up and pay for space
and like there's definitely better ways
to do this and yeah it was completely
unscalable but it did like prove our
point which is good so um we have kind
of a two-sided thing where we have
donors and the people that actually need
the help and so if you follow me on
Twitter I'm sorry but that's like the
the way that we got the initial donors
but we had all this money that kind of
piled up as far as pledges go
and since we've done everything on
social media we didn't know how to
access or like get to the people that
needed the actual money but what ended
up happening is just like we got really
low-tech and we just like design some
postcards and send them to people and so
like if you the USPS has like a way
where you can just like target certain
blocks and just kind of like say you
want to send you know 500 postcards to
this street it's like kind of
gerrymander the way it looks like but
like we ended up just kind of doing that
and just kind of going from our database
and just saying we have a lot of people
from Detroit in this zip code that are
applying so why not just target that
entire zip code we just started doing
that kind of thing so these people were
not on social media so we couldn't just
keep tweeting for them and actually
maybe I'll talk about it later but the
city wasn't helping us either because
they were kind of like who the hell are
you so they were just you know we didn't
get help in that way so we kind of had
to like just hack it in that way and it
turned out to be a really interesting
sort of thing to send out postcards so
the next one is find 10 to 100 customers
that really love your product so how did
you determine that people were loving
your product like how did you define
that either qualitative orally or
quantitatively so I'll continue along
the same story so for us once we started
you know listing these products from
Craigslist and trying to we got our
first sale and we're like wow okay what
are we going to do to actually fulfill
this sale because these sellers don't
even know that we've listed their
product and our platform so we were
trying to figure out how to fulfill that
order so you know the first time I tried
I email how I am the co-op deco you know
we sold your product on App Deco and you
know we're gonna pay you and it just
didn't work that nobody responded so
then we just realized like hey like why
don't we just actually just pretend like
work Craigslist shopper go on their path
I go and just email them like hey I'm
gonna buy and we just paid them in cash
and that's what we did
the most amazing thing that happened out
of that is because we were actually
visiting every person's home we were
talking to our customers and we realized
once we told them why we started the
this cuz once we got to their home we
would tell them hey this is by the way
abductor this is what we do etc they
were like wow this is amazing they
actually started telling all their
friends so every time we went and we
were doing something very unscalable
5-10 people signed up as a result of it
so that was the genesis of sort of
getting from you know 10 to a hundred
customers referrals basically we've
pretty great Zach and yeah I feel like
we had like a pretty similar experience
where once we started getting referrals
from brands we felt like okay like we're
doing something good enough that people
are recommending their friends I think
we got lucky because our our users
they're in this tight-knit community of
brands and so they all would talk to
each other and if someone sold in our
store for a few months and they were
making good money like they're gonna
tell someone else in their community and
yeah I think it was like when we opened
the third store and we just were able to
like book it out immediately and we like
couldn't believe that people were paying
like pretty healthy rates to sell in the
store and yeah it was just like finally
getting to a point where we were doing
something right for the users yeah I
mean so the first but again from donors
versus people that were helping so the
donor side was again just social media
and it turned into like the news finding
out about us and the people signing it
from there and that became like me
getting stuck in my apartment for like
two weeks talking to press over and over
again about what we were doing because
it was kind of weird if you think about
it to pay somebody else's water bill
so people were kind of fascinated with
that aspect but then as far as the
people we helped again it's the post
cars but then like you know Facebook
groups and stuff like that so so let's
talk a little bit about competitors so
the common advice is just ignore it
you're growing your startup it you know
starts are going to die because of
suicide not murder so how do you guys
think about competitors
it's definitely it's easier said than
done to ignore them for sure but you
know I've learned through time now where
this is our fifth year in businesses
that is really the best advice is to try
to ignore them and what I've learned
over time is you know just focus on the
things you can control and you can
control make delighting your customers
you can control making you know a
product that people want and things of
like things of that nature we've had
competitors that have raised you know
tons more money than we have to date
even and they've shut down so it doesn't
really matter at the end it's all about
the execution and just focus on the
things that will make you you know
compete in the market yeah I think we
try and ignore them as much as possible
also I definitely have like my Google
Alert set to say like if when they
announce certain things and I think you
know we'll look to see how they're
positioning their product in the market
or when they're raising money but yeah I
think like the more you can just keep
your blinders on and look at your
metrics and look at your milestones and
keep your team looking at that and not
be like oh my god they just raised
twenty three million dollars like what
are we gonna do it's just it's
distracting and it doesn't really help
you in any way yes sir the
not-for-profit sector is a little
different because there's they're still
totally competition like it's not just
this like Oh everybody's like trying to
help the world or whatever because it's
actually surprisingly cutthroat which I
learned kind of on-the-job maybe if you
pull me afterwards I'll tell you about
certain mafia s phone calls I got from
other organizations I'm not I'm not even
kidding but like just for us has been
like learning how to like communicate
the work that we're doing really well
and also just kind of pulling in
people's heartstrings and like learning
how to do the storytelling and then also
eventually you butted heads with the
cities a little bit q so what's that we
bought you bought it heads with the
cities a little bit or they weren't a
couple at all no so I think when we
launched we embarrassed Detroit which
wasn't the which wasn't the goal we just
helped people when they didn't and so
they they didn't
I mean it's true it's true so they they
told people not to come to us for help
because they're like well you know if
you need help come to us but they
weren't helping people they were turning
off cancer patients for crying out loud
and this is kind of stuff that was going
on but we got a call from a certain very
big nonprofit so national organization
and they saw us as competition which was
funny because I was still like operating
this out of my bedroom basically as a
fundraising thing but it's just a
principle that you know we got more
press people were this what we were
doing was resonating with people more
and we could show actual like success
stories and we weren't like building six
houses with hundreds of millions of
dollars and that kind of thing so I
think that's the nonprofit sector has
competition still but I think if you
like show that you operate better you're
actually using the money for what you
say you are and you're like putting
those success stories out and then
you're talking about like the systemic
change that you're trying to actually
kick off that actually resonates with
people that's the question I get all the
time too like how are you gonna do this
like what's the long term sort of plan
and for us it's actually not to keep
raising money but it's actually to like
have laws passed around water
affordability and just kind of use like
a lot of startup s principles to do that
so cool so it's often said that you
shouldn't start scaling as in hiring
lots of people until you find product
market fit
so maybe Keith we kind of went over and
we talked about referrals and stuff like
that but maybe you can go over when did
you know you should hire your first
person who was your first important hire
and why did you hire that person product
market fit for us was when we decided to
take on delivery and make it in-house so
when we started the business we did not
want to touch the furniture we just
wanted to provide the platform a year
and so into it we were working with
third party moving companies we realized
that it's just a quality of service was
not up to par and they were just
canceling jobs on us last minute so we
hired some guys off of Garza's again and
and rented as a van and that day you
know we had incredible feedback from
customers fast forward you know now we
have over ten trucks in the city and
what we saw was as soon as we brought
delivery now
you know we talked about referral but
really it skyrocketed the type of
referrals the quality of services well
the branding also our metrics we now
understand our metrics very well and
that that was really the the basis for
it I mean our first hire was customer
service because it was all about
delighting customers and what I learned
over time is you know your needs as a
business change over time so our first
hire was customer service and that was
at the time the most important hire we
fast forward a couple of years later our
head of operations and obviously our
engineers etc yeah for us it took us
about a year and a half before we got to
product market fit like we pivoted so
many times and just kept taking like the
little things we learn and use it for
like the next version of the company
we'd run but yeah it literally wasn't a
year and a half until we got to a point
where we were opening retail stores they
were working the brands were happy and
then to answer your question about the
hiring I think our first important hire
is really what got us to like full
product market fit in my mind there was
basically a point where we were treating
the stores as like the store stores as a
service like any brand can come and sell
their product and so we ended up with
this like crazy store where there is
like Fitbit competitors next to blankets
and it just didn't make sense obviously
and so we hired our Director of Product
Maggi brain she came from j.crew who
just totally transformed the business
she's a merchandiser and so she was able
to really pick the right brands pick the
right products and price point and I
mean the stores just took off after that
but it was like that final key higher
before we were like okay like we can
scale this we're good yeah for us
product market fit is just like having
people continue to support us basically
so we've been trying to build a stronger
recurring Giving Program so that's still
kind of in the works actually because
like I had never run a non-profit before
so I didn't know like what we should
actually be doing and like what that
looks like as far as success besides
like changing laws so we're still doing
that but as far as like their first hire
we had it was also customer service
because like you know we had all these
people that were applying for help that
like I couldn't talk to them all on my
own
we talked about stuff that didn't scale
I was turning into kind of like a social
worker slash therapist but I like
talking to everybody who like seriously
like who everybody who applied I talked
to them on the phone for at least 30
minutes which was good in the beginning
because like people were feeling heard
for once because then you deal with a
lot of people that are in poverty the
thing that's common among soliton is
they they could overlooked and ignored
and so we just kind of I just listened
to people more but Kate who used to
direct nonprofits at YC she kept telling
me like you need to hire somebody
because you're looking worse and worse
then every time I see you and you can't
like you know you can't do this on your
own and like what not so I actually the
spring of 2016 I'm an engineer by the
way too so like I took like a month off
from everything else and just built out
what became our case management system
and then that allowed me to actually
hire the customer service person because
they would have had the no rails
otherwise because while we had was the
rails console but that was our first
customer I mean I'm sorry first hire so
am I related to that is when when
founders come into YC we we say please
please remember to get some sleep and
some exercise so how do you guys stay
sane while running a startup or do you
still still trying to figure that one
out yeah so this year at least I'm
trying to make it to gym more and travel
it's still work-in-progress but
definitely it's very very important and
what I learned over time is you know
it's not about the number of hours it's
or about how productive you are you can
work six hours and be more productive
than working 15 hours in a day so I'm
trying to still implement that but it's
yeah it's very very important yeah I
think for us I mean it's something where
it ABB's and flows like there's there's
weeks where things are just completely
insane and we're opening a new store and
I just feel like very unhealthy not okay
and I think the whole team gets that way
sometimes but yeah I mean I think when
we do have like kind of a Down moment
like trying just to really take
advantage of it and just you know not go
into the office on the weekend
running has really helped me I know like
a lot of people hate running I used to
oh but for like just my mental ste like
running has done wonders for me so yeah
I know people hate it but maybe try it I
mean I so this is actually the end of my
vacation this week I was like literally
I was on vacation this entire week which
never happens but the three things that
I've been doing more is like going to
therapy I work with an executive coach
that helps me like stay organized and
prioritize and things like that and then
like something I started in the last
couple months is acupuncture because
it's helped with like energy issues and
like actually getting me to sit down
somewhere like during the business day
so those are really good things I know
or over time but I apologize but I want
to add in one more question because I
think it's so important and that is
advice is founder relationships matter
more than you think so can you talk
about your relationship with your
co-founder and how do you guys say
saying with each other and balance
things so for us I have a co-founder and
so my background man engineer and he
came from marketing in sales
so early on we tried to create
delineation of roles and you know we
butt heads still all the time but at the
end of the day someone has to make the
final decision because it's all if it
was always a democracy and we both have
to come consensus we're just never going
to move forward move quickly so what we
do is you know any product really things
I essentially have to final say any
marketing really thinks he has the final
say for example we run subway campaigns
I really did not want to spend the money
and he was like well we're gonna do it
and we did and actually worked out to be
very well but you know I think this is
the important thing is creating that
sort of making sure that you have a
structure where you're able to make
decisions fast and quickly and conflicts
okay but you have to figure out a
healthy way to manager as well yeah I
feel like I just got so lucky with my
co-founder Ally like we have very
complementary and different like skill
sets and personalities like I'm more
introverted I like to kind of manage
things from behind the scenes she is
like the total opposite she's like
highly extroverted
amazing salesperson amazing press person
and so we work really well together and
I think even from the very beginning
when it was just the two of us like
working in my apartment we just could
kind of like stay in our own lanes like
I just knew what I was good at what she
was good at and yeah we just we worked
really well together and so yeah I think
when you're looking for your co-founder
even if it's not like she's the
technical one on the non-technical one
like I don't think it needs to be like
that but looking at like different
personality types and even soft skill
sets it really helps to have a little
bit of a mix there I think so my
original co-founder couldn't go through
YC with me but she's like a very
dedicated donor advisor at the
organization but the next person that I
think of that it's been around just as
long technically is my the customer
service person I hired Marie she's I I'm
the fundraiser and the person that like
does all the technical stuff but she
does the customer service which again I
burnt out on but other thing is she's
really good with his people like I I
still labor under the belief that this
is ridiculous I have to do this as an
organization but she is just kind of
like you know okay I'll call the city
people and talk to them for you because
I'm on the phone like why the hell can't
you do this or whatever and she's
patient enough to be like you know I
will talk to them I will make this work
for us or what not and she's way better
that stuff than I am because I'm just
like to me common sense this shouldn't
have to be a thing but she's able to
talk to people and kind of finesse them
and whatnot so I really like appreciate
that aspect of the work she does cool
awesome well that's it if you can give
these three a round of applause thank
you so much
[Applause]
you